françois poulet mathis journalistes
spécialistes europe bonsoir françois où
les métis merci d'être avec nous alors
concrètement qu on essaye d'y voir plus
clair que reproche-t-on à ursula von der
leyen
on lui reproche lorsqu'elle était
ministre de la défense c'est à dire en
charge de la bundeswehr d'avoir fait
appel à des cabinets privés à des
consultants sans véritable considération
des sommes qui étaient demandés et donc
c'est une centaine de millions qui sont
directement en cause de consultants
privés qui seraient intervenus sans
qu'elle apparemment elle en est le
contrôle au moins c'est ce qu'elle dit
qu'on se défendre c'est quand même grave
dans la mesure où ces cabinets privés
laisse passer l'idée que le ministère de
la défense c'est à dire un ministère
régalien seraient infiltrés par des
intérêts qui ne sont pas des intérêts
d'état est donc là la critique est
étendue lieuse pour ursula von der leyen
cela dit on connaissait cette critique
au moment où elle est partie à bruxelles
est précisément d'ailleurs les allemands
considéré qu' angela merkel d'une
certaine manière lui avait donné une
porte de sortie de protection en
envoyant à bruxelles ce qui permettait
relativement de la protéger
donc elle est vraiment sur le grill elle
est sur le grill mais il faut peut-être
attendre vous l'avez signalé d'ailleurs
de rire de la conclusion de la
commission denquête qui réunit
opposition et majorité et donc qui
réunit le parti d'angela merkel avec
l'opposition qui jusqu'à maintenant
était la seule à l'avoir mis en cause
donc il faut voir ce que ça va donner
effectivement d'ici une semaine je ne
pense pas que ça puisse remettre en
cause son poste à la commission mais il
faut quand même dire que le démarrage de
mandat de ursula von der leyen était pas
facile pas facile parce qu'elle est
partie de manière assez précipité du
ministère de la défense alors qu'elle
était promise à de grandes destinées on
lui même
on lui prédisait même eu un poste de
chancelière à la limite
et puis cette affaire-là effectivement
là un petit peu plombé et puis son
démarrage à bruxelles n'a pas été non
plus très concluants dans la mesure où
les députés européens espérer avoir un
candidat à la présidence de la
commission qui soit le reflet de la
majorité acquise aux élections
européennes et donc en l'occurrence
c'était le socialiste qui ferment ce qui
devait arriver or là ursula von der
leyen a été le fruit d'un compromis
entre emmanuel macron et angela merkel
donc elle est arrivée dans des
conditions qui n'étaient pas des
conditions optimales le dernier obstacle
et qui n'est pas le moine c'est là que
compte tenu du fait que l'allemagne a
démarré assez tard mais le virus le
corps navires us et dans des conditions
beaucoup plus favorables que ça a été le
cas en italie en espagne et bien se fait
donner l'impression que ursula von der
leyen une fois la commission était plus
allemande que présidente de la
commission donc elle n'a pas
véritablement mesurer l'importance de ce
coronavirus et l'importance de la
pandémie qui arrive et si bien qu'elle a
agi un petit peu en retard la commission
agit en retard elle a été finalement au
coeur de ce reproche que l'on a fait à
la commission de ne pas avoir été tout
de suite aux manettes pour éviter ce
dérapage ce désordre auquel on a assisté
au démarrage de la pandémie
alors les partisans à d'ursula von der
leyen estiment eux qui n'étaient pas au
courant des irrégularités dans
l'attribution de missions de conseil
s'interroge on peut se poser la question
est ce possible quand un ministre ne
soit pas au courant de ce qui se passe
au sein son propre ministère c'est toute
la question c'est toute la question est
de quelle confiance peut tel bénéficié
dans les proclamations de bonne foi qui
est là en disant qu' elle n'avait
n'était absolument pas au courant parce
que c'était pas de son niveau ce qui est
quand même relativement grave parce que
voir des cabinets privés qui s'empare
d'une certaine manière de consulter de
consultants de poste de consultant pour
des questions relativement stratégique
c'est quand même inquiétant pour un
ministère de la défense qui je le
rappelle est quand même un ministère
régalien en allemagne donc on peu aussi
mais effectivement que cette affaire
n'est pas terminée
cela dit je pense que la semaine
prochaine lorsqu'on aura les résultats
de l' enquête
jointe opposition et majorité peut-être
que les choses vont se clarifier un
petit peu dans la mesure où angela
merkel est bien décidé à défendre coûte
que coûte sa candidate qui est urgent de
la mort d'un des leurs alors tout de
même louis effectivement les ça devrait
être rendu de la semaine prochaine est
ce que ça pourrait al'inverse donner des
conséquences judiciaires
c'est possible mais il faudra prouver
c'est toujours le problème des preuves
photos et quelles preuves
est ce que véritablement elle n'était
pas au courant et ça c'est chez nous une
véritable enquête judiciaire qui doit
être mené en allemagne
cela dit c'est vrai que étant à
bruxelles elle est relativement protégé
donc elle a un poste qui la protège
c'est un petit peu d'ailleurs ce qu'on
lui avait reproché c'est d'aller à
bruxelles sous forme de fuite en quelque
sorte mais ça on ne peut pas s'exprimer
pour l'instant il faudra que l'anc est
allé plus loin
pour l'instant cette affaire fait
beaucoup de bruit parce que je le
rappelle c'est l'opposition les verts
notamment
c'est eux qui émettent en avance cette
culpabilité évalué de l'asian donc c'est
pas encore prouvé cette affaire n'aura
ses suites
en tout cas à l'ombre du soupçon jamais
bon effectivement pour une réputation à
la commission européenne peut-être se
permettre d'avoir à sa tête quelqu'un
soupçonnés de fraude
oui il ya eu des cas semblables dans le
passé on a vu des commissaires et pas
des moindres qui ont connu comme ça des
situations appliquée dans des cabinets
de consulting notamment un petit peu le
même genre de situation ça peut se veut
ça peut se produire
en attendant la commission à européenne
je le rappelle c'est quand même une
structure qui est européenne et qui est
donc au-delà des pays aux à des parties
ou l'inde et pays et donc pour qu'une
commission pour qu'une enquête puisse la
toucher directement
il faut effectivement que les services
de la commission soit directement engagé
et a monté une enquête eux de leur côté
effectivement pour essayer de mettre
sous la dent des layènes devant
d'éventuelles contradictions mais pour
l'instant c'est encore trop tôt pour le
dire
si françois paul et mathis d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france